I knew the ribosome was important but to
be honest many awards have gone to the
ribosome and but but not to me and so I
had gradually lowered my expectations of
any such award so I actually thought
initially that it was a prank call and
because I have friends who do play this
sort of prank of course it would be a
kind of cruel prank but I nevertheless
didn't really quite believe it and I
asked to actually speak to a member of
the committee whom I know because he's a
well-known ribosome scientist and when I
heard his voice then it really sank in
with a shock that it was real so huh
well I like to joke that ever since
Rutherford a knowledge of chemistry is
not a prerequisite for this whole horde
because actually I think I would flunk
an undergraduate chemistry exam so I'm
kind of tickled to here to get a
chemistry Nobel Prize
the ribosome is a large macromolecular
machine it's a molecular machine that
consists of over a million atoms its
role in all cells is to take the genetic
information encoded in DNA which is
normally in the form of a double helix
now DNA gets copied to messenger RNA and
both DNA and RNA contain a sequence of
the building blocks of nucleic acid and
that sequence specifies the sequence of
amino acids that make up a protein but
to go from the language of nucleic acids
which has four types of building block
to the language of proteins which has 20
types of amino acids requires a
translating machine and that complex
translating machine is the ribosome and
the reason that's so important is
because many of the really catalytic
activities of the cell and structures of
the cell are made up of protein
by the time I started working on it
quite a lot was known it was known that
there were two subunits the small
subunit would bind this messenger RNA
the large subunit would form the peptide
bond that antibiotics targeted the
ribosome the problem was to go from
there to a detailed understanding of the
ribosome was very difficult and that's
because the ribosome is as I told you
enormous it's over a million atoms and
people made a number of valiant efforts
over the years which really vastly
improved our understanding of the
ribosome but ultimately I think a
high-resolution structure would it was
clear that that would elevate our
understanding to a new level that's what
allows you to know where the atoms are
and unless you know where the atoms are
you don't know where the bonds are what
what's bonding with what what the
interactions are and so we can't
interpret things in chemical terms and
this is why I think the high resolution
structures really change everything the
idea of trying to get an atomic
structure of the ribosome really goes
back to our day on earth who's one of
the co winners of this Nobel Prize and
she decided to try and crystallize the
entire ribosome or ribosomal subunits
and initially her crystals weren't very
good there were a number of technical
difficulties because no one had solved a
structure nearly as big as a ribosome it
was a tremendous feeling because to
actually see you know these proteins and
large strands of RNA in the electron
density meant we'd crack the problem and
then it was a question of just improving
the resolution to the point where we
could ex
interpreted in atomic terms that was a
thrilling period if you think of these
crystal structures they're like
snapshots of a particular state of the
molecule and as you know from looking at
any machine like a car engine machines
move to consume energy to do all sorts
of things and so if you want to
understand how the ribosome works you
need to get that snapshot at different
stages of the process and that's still
an ongoing work in many different labs
and that's what we'd like but of course
that sort of snapshot isn't really going
to tell us everything or even much of
the story either I think the ultimate
story will come from a combined effort
from biochemists geneticists people who
look at single molecule techniques so
all these techniques are going to help
unravel exactly how the ribosome works
that's going to take many years but I
think knowing what the fundamental
architecture is in molecular terms makes
all of this other work much more
powerful
so I'm kind of dismayed to see this this
constant emphasis on translational
research drowning out the idea that it's
our basic research that provides the
seed corn from which we can have
translational research without these
kinds of fundamental discoveries and I
should tell you the ribosome right after
the structures were determined has
already been started to be used for
antibiotic design but that's not why we
did it okay and many discoveries like
DNA sequencing monoclonal antibodies
they're all billion-dollar industries
now and so you know you should have both
but there has to be the recognition that
really fundamental silent research pays
for itself many many times over in terms
of eventual discoveries and technology
and if you support that foundation the
rest will follow I think you simply
cannot do science in order to get a
Nobel Prize that's that's a route to
failure and unhappiness okay I think
people should pursue science because
they're interested in it that you pick a
problem that they love that they care
about that they're dying to know the
answer to and then the prizes or the
lack of prizes simply doesn't matter if
the Nobel Prize didn't exist we would
all still be very happy in fact we will
be happier because of this limitation of
three and excluding really important
contributions so we'd actually be
happier in some sense if these prizes
didn't exist and we pursued knowledge
for its own sake